-The president is facing
three more days
of impeachment hearings
this week after a second day
of damning testimony
and yet another conviction
of one of his associates.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, if you've been following
the impeachment hearings,
I know what
you've been thinking.
Where...is...the...evidence?
I mean, only six
of the president's
closest aides and associates
have been convicted
or pled guilty to crimes.
I mean, who among us doesn't
have at least six work friends
who are also criminals?
I mean, we all know
every friend group has a Carrie,
a Miranda, a Charlotte,
and a Roger who looks like Mary
Poppins' coked-up ex-boyfriend.
That, of course, is Roger Stone,
a long-time associate
of President Trump in his actual
outfit from the inauguration.
And on Friday,
Stone opened his magic umbrella
and teleported himself to jail.
-Roger Stone, the
self-proclaimed dirty trickster
and long-time associate of
President Donald Trump, an ally,
was found guilty
in federal court
of witness tampering
and lying to Congress
about his pursuit
of Russian hacked e-mails
damaging to Hillary Clinton's
2016 election bid.
-Man, who could have guessed
this guy was a criminal?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, he looks like
a character
from the 1960s
Adam West "Batman."
[ Laughter ]
When they closed the door
of his jail cell,
it'll go, "Wham! Clink! Pow!"
Stone is now at least
the sixth Trump associate
who's been convicted of
or pled guilty to a crime,
and I am not including Trump's
current lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
who we found out Friday is
under federal investigation
for his links
to Ukrainian energy projects
or two of Rudy's associates,
Lev and Igor, who were arrested
in part for their role in this
whole Ukraine scheme.
Remember these two?
This looks like a before
and after picture
except it is before
and even more before.
They look like
they got their start
in a live-action game
of Whack-a-Mole.
They look like they got fired
from their jobs as mall Santas
for stealing
from the food court.
[ Russian accent ]
"We thought Auntie Anne's
was free for Santa.
Why would Auntie charge?"
[ Normal voice ] In fact,
on Friday, we also found out
that these two dummies met
privately with Trump
at the White House,
and that they later told people
they'd been given a secret
mission by Trump himself.
-We've learned that both
of the men had a meeting
with the president and Rudy
Giuliani last year
at the White House's
annual Hanukkah party
where they discussed
what Parnas described
as a secret mission to pressure
the Ukrainian government
to investigate
former Vice President Joe Biden
and his son Hunter.
-Days later we are told that
Parnas insinuated to people
that he clearly believed he had
been given a special assignment
by the president, some sort of,
and I'm quoting here,
"James Bond mission."
-That's right.
These guys thought they were on
a James Bond mission for Trump.
I'm sorry,
but these guys aren't 007.
They're just double Os.
This is one where I might
believe Trump over them.
I mean, I can imagine them
cornering Trump
in a long, boring conversation
about Van Damme movies
and canned fish,
and Trump trying to get out of
it by just going,
[ As Trump ]
"Hey, will you guys go on, like,
a secret mission for me?"
[ Normal voice ] By the way,
while all this was happening,
the House was also conducting
its second day
of public impeachment hearings
with the former ambassador
to Ukraine, Marie Yovanovitch.
Basically, Yovanovitch was
the subject of a smear campaign
by Giuliani and was
abruptly pushed out by Trump
because they knew
she would be an obstacle
to their corrupt scheme.
She is a career foreign-service
officer whose credibility is
unquestioned by anyone
in either party,
so, naturally,
as she was testifying,
Trump decided to attack her.
-The president attacking former
U.S. Ambassador to Ukraine
Marie Yovanovitch
during her public testimony
tweeting, in part,
"Everywhere Marie Yovanovitch
went turned bad.
She started off in Somalia.
How did that go?
Then fast-forward to Ukraine
where the new Ukrainian
President spoke unfavorably
about her in my second
phone call with him."
-Everywhere she went
turned bad?!
You've gone bankrupt six times
and botched everything
from casinos to your charity
to your dumb-ass businesses.
You made a vodka so bad,
no one would drink it.
Vodka!
How do you screw up vodka?!
Only Trump.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Only Trump could take something
that's supposed to be flavorless
and make it taste like [bleep].
But the worst part is
Trump tweeted this
while she was testifying.
He tried to intimidate
an impeachment witness
in real time.
So, she responded in real time.
And not only was it
a bad look for Trump,
but legal analysts
also suggested
his tweet might have been
a crime.
-As we sit here testifying,
the president is attacking you
on Twitter.
What effect do you think
that has on other witnesses'
willingness to come forward
and expose wrongdoing?
-Well, it's very intimidating.
-It's designed to intimidate,
is it not?
-I mean, I can't speak to what
the president is trying to do,
but I think the effect is
to be intimidating.
-I think there's a good argument
that given
all the circumstances here,
given the timing right
in the middle
of this person's testimony,
given the nature of the tweet,
that it could be
witness tampering
or witness retaliation.
-This could fit
into federal laws
that are broadly defined
in terms of witness tampering.
-That's right -- Trump committed
witness tampering
during an impeachment hearing.
That's like punching the bailiff
during your assault trial.
[ Laughter ]
But I think I know
what he's doing here.
You see, Trump figures
if he just keeps committing
impeachable offenses, Democrats
will have to keep investigating
those offenses
which means they'll never
actually have time
to impeach him.
He thinks he can just keep
committing crimes
to run out the clock.
At the next hearing, he's going
to drop in from the ceiling
and steal everyone's wallets
like Tom Cruise
in "Mission Impossible."
In fact, this was so bad
that even Fox News had to admit
when it happened that Trump
had only strengthened
the impeachment case
against him.
-The president was not advised
by counsel
in deciding to do this tweet.
Extraordinarily poor judgment.
-And that does raise
the possibility
of witness intimidation
and witness tampering
as a new charge here.
-This whole hearing
turned on a dime
when the president tweeted
about her real time.
Now, that enabled Schiff
to then characterize that tweet
as intimidating the witness
or tampering with the witness,
which is a crime,
adding essentially an article
of impeachment real time.
-That's right.
Trump added
another article of impeachment
in real time.
At this point he should just
start doing
DVD director's commentary
during the hearings.
-[ As Trump ] "As you can see
here, that's Marie Yovanovitch.
I pushed her out so I could
bribe the president of Ukraine.
That was a fun scene.
And, oh, here's Jim Jordan.
We pulled a prank on set
where we stole Jim's jacket."
[ Normal voice ] Still,
if you're Republican, I get it.
It's just so hard to say.
Is Trump innocent,
or is he guilty?
I mean, all we have so far is
the six Trump associates
convicted of a crime,
two more indicted associates
saying they were
on a secret mission for him,
his lawyer
under criminal investigation,
Trump himself committing
witness tampering,
the whistle-blower's account
claiming the president clearly
committed a criminal act,
the notes from the call,
in which Trump mentions
the Bidens multiple times,
the part of the call
where Trump tells
the Ukrainian President
"I would like you
to do us a favor,"
the president's chief of staff
literally confessing
on national television,
Rudy Giuliani going on TV
and bragging about
what he was doing,
and, like,
a bunch of witnesses saying,
"Yes, there was a quid pro quo."
I'm sorry!
That's not enough to convict!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Republicans won't budge
unless we have a photo
of Trump on the phone
with a word bubble coming
out of his mouth saying,
"I am doing a crime now."
I mean, just take
that quote where Trump told
the president of Ukraine,
"I would like you to do us
a favor."
We just have no way of knowing
what he really meant.
It's not like Trump has said
himself on camera
for the entire world to see
that he wanted
the president of Ukraine
to start a major investigation
into the Bidens.
-What exactly did you hope
Zelensky would do
about the Bidens
after your phone call?
-Well, I would think that if
they were honest about it,
they'd start a major
investigation into the Bidens.
It's a very simple answer.
They should investigate
the Bidens.
-Damn it, Donald!
Why are you so coy?!
But in case you still needed
more evidence
tying Trump directly
to the scheme
to extort a foreign country
to investigate
his political rivals
by dangling hundreds
of millions of dollars
in taxpayer money,
you got that evidence
from last week's
impeachment hearings.
Multiple witnesses tied Trump
and his lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
directly to the quid pro quo,
and one witness,
Ambassador Bill Taylor,
even revealed
some bombshell new information
about a phone call Trump had had
with one of his key henchmen,
the Ambassador to the E.U.,
Gordon Sondland.
-Taylor said a staffer of his
recently told him
about this conversation
involving the president
and the Trump donor
turned ambassador to the E.U.,
Gordon Sondland.
-In the presence of my staff
at a restaurant,
Ambassador Sondland
called President Trump
and told him of his meetings
in Kiev.
The member of my staff
could hear President Trump
on the phone
asking Ambassador Sondland
about the investigations.
-This was a cellphone I take it?
-It was a cellphone.
-The president must have been
speaking loud enough
for your staff member
to be able to overhear this?
-He was.
-These guys are such morons.
Trump was in the process
of committing a crime,
and he was screaming
into the phone so loudly,
everyone on the other end
could hear him.
That's what happens
when you're used to doing
all your press conferences
outside
next to a giant helicopter.
It's like taking a date
to a Metallica concert.
[ Shouting ] "I'm having
a really great time tonight!"
"What?!"
"I said I'm having
a really great time tonight!"
"Did you say you'd like
to commit a crime tonight?"
"Yeah!"
[ Normal voice ]
Trump yelled so loud,
everyone could hear him.
Honestly,
it would have been easier
if Trump had just held
a conference call
and let everyone dial in.
-President Trump has joined
the conference call.
-Hello, everybody. Thank you
very much for being here.
Ukraine --
To investigate the Bidens.
And I'm -- guilty.
-This conference call
has ended.
-So, a witness
literally overheard Trump
yelling about his crime
on a phone call
with one of his key henchmen.
And just in case it wasn't
already incredibly clear
what had happened on that call,
we found out on Friday from that
witness what happened next.
The witness, a State Department
official named David Holmes,
testified that after Sondland
hung up with Trump,
he basically admitted everything
on the spot.
-Following the call
with President Trump,
the member of my staff
asked Ambassador Sondland
what President Trump thought
about Ukraine.
Ambassador Sondland responded
that President Trump
cares more about
the investigations of Biden,
which Giuliani was pressing for.
-I want to a read section
from Holmes' sworn testimony,
his opening statement.
"In particular,
I asked Ambassador Sondland,"
this is David Holmes speaking,
"if it true that the president
did not give a [bleep]" --
excuse the language --
"about Ukraine.
Ambassador Sondland agreed
that the president
did not give a [bleep]
about Ukraine."
-He literally hung up the phone
and said Trump doesn't give
a [bleep] about Ukraine.
He only cares about
investigating the Bidens.
He just admitted it.
It's like if you saw your spouse
on their phone
and said,
"Are you texting a friend?"
and they said, "Honey,
she's more than a friend.
She's my mistress."
[ Laughter ]
So, Friday's deposition could
not have made it any more clear.
Not only did Trump try to extort
the president of Ukraine
during his own phone call with
that country's president,
Trump was also calling
other key players in the scheme
and checking in with them, too.
In fact during his deposition
on Friday, Holmes also said
that he overheard Sondland
and Trump discussing
the pressure campaign directed
toward Ukrainian President
Zelensky and what he heard was
both very colorful
and very damning.
-"I heard Ambassador Sondland
greet the president
and explain that he was calling
from Kiev.
I heard President Trump
then clarify
that Ambassador Sondland was
in Ukraine.
Ambassador Sondland replied,
Yes, he was in Ukraine,
and went on to state
that President Zelensky
"loves your ass."
-That's right Trump's henchman
actually told him,
"Zelensky loves your ass."
I mean, it's
classic bad-guy talk.
That's something the
wolf of wall street would say
after snorting cocaine
off a stripper's butt.
"Whoo! Daddy loves your ass!"
Now, Trump has denied ever
taking the call from Sondland
despite the fact that
we now have multiple witnesses
confirming it, although,
it's clear from his denial
that Trump was,
as always, lying.
-There was one moment where
Ambassador Bill Taylor recounted
a conversation
that an aide of his overheard
in which the aide says
that he overheard you
say to Sondland,
"How are things proceeding
with the investigations?"
Is that correct,
and can you fill in some more?
-I know nothing about that.
First time I've heard it.
-Do you recall a conversation --
-I don't recall. No.
Not at all.
-Yeah but you do.
Any time Trump says he doesn't
recall, he definitely recalls.
He always does this.
You can show flash cards
of the people closest to him
in his life, and he'd pretend
he doesn't recognize them.
-[ As Trump ] "What?
No, never met him.
Doesn't look familiar.
Is he an extra
in 'The Walking Dead?'"
[ Laughter ]
-"I don't know."
-[ Normal voice ]
Trump has pulled this move
so many times, and every time,
we found out that he's lying.
Remember
when the news first broke
that his lawyer Michael Cohen
had illegally paid off
Stormy Daniels to cover up
Trump's affair with her?
Trump denied
knowing anything about it,
but we later found out
that Trump had reimbursed Cohen
and orchestrated
the whole thing.
In fact, we literally saw
a copy of the check
Trump wrote to Cohen.
And you can tell it's Trump's
signature because it looks like
he was trying to draw a straight
line while riding a seesaw.
We already have all the evidence
we can possibly need,
and there's still more witnesses
waiting to testify.
Republicans have no defense.
All they can do
during these hearings
is perform for Trump
to earn his approval.
I wouldn't be surprised
if at some point this week,
a GOP congressman looked
directly into the camera
and said, "President Trump,
the Republican Party --
-Loves your ass.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]